so many changes going on in your your
lives alana a lot of changes going on in
your life yeah i also understand that
you are going to be undergoing a
physical transformation so is it true
that you're going to undergo a weight
loss surgery end of august
it's still in the works like there is a
story that come out and it's not 100 yet
dodo i think she had just had it done
and i just want to make sure that like
this is actually something i want to do
before i just go and do it i want to
make sure that it's like not something
that's like going to kill me or nothing
and i just want to make sure it's
something i actually want to do before i
go and do it that makes sense i mean but
what led you to weighing this as an
option
mainly because i know for a fact i could
get in the gym and i never had i could
diet i know how i can do this have you
been doing those things i have tried i
will say i have tried but the one thing
with me is i have no motivation i have
no motivation to just keep going to the
gym every day i have no motivation to
keep eating healthy because like i'm
gonna eat what i think is good i'm not
gonna sit here and force myself to eat
no caesar salad
because i think it's healthy no i'm
gonna eat what i think is good yeah so i
just think i don't have no motivation
and i feel like the surgery would be
like probably the easiest way to just
like lose it fast okay but let me just
have some girl talk with you we see what
mama june went through
and she didn't maintain it because she
wasn't willing to change her lifestyle
also the same way our older sister so
are you willing to change your lifestyle
you said you don't have the motivation
if i do go through with the surgery i
think then i would be willing to change
my lifestyle because if i go through
with the surgery my manager told me like
you basically lose 100 pounds basically
instant do you have a goal in mind of
where you'd like to be um i definitely
want to be like around like the one like
45 rings
i don't want to be like super skinny i
don't want to be like a girl that is
super skinny 145
i mean it's not super skinny but i don't
want to be like
110 like no no i definitely don't want
to be there but it's all what's going to
be healthiest for you and your body and
what you can maintain you know so do you
feel like is there a part of you that
feels like genetics plays the part too
there is a part that does feel like i
that genetics does play because
when i was very young i was on steroids
so
like i was very sick all the time and i
just always had to take medication so
i was always bigger a bigger
kid anyways because of that and then my
mom she um claims she has this thing
called lymphedemia that supposedly makes
her have some fat on her body so i mean
that could be possible like
i don't know i mean i definitely do eat
so that's definitely a reason but i
don't know it's all good so you haven't
made the final decision or you have you
are going through with the surgery um i
haven't made a hundred percent like i
want to do it you're still very
skeptical about it
100
like let's do it but me i just think
like it's the going it's like them
putting me to sleep for me like i'm
always just so nervous like what if i
don't get wake up like what if something
goes bad or that it's like
and then like
i just don't know like what if something
goes wrong you know i mean that doesn't
i don't want to be debbie downer over
here but it is
yeah it's a possibility so pumpkin where
do you and josh jam with this um so i'm
really happy for alana if that's
something that she really wants to do um
i definitely think before she takes that
big step which i haven't told her this
yet but i do think before she takes that
big step she needs to go ahead and start
making the lifestyle changes
because it's not i know it's a lot
easier just to be like okay let me go
out to you know california or whatever
let me get my stomach chopped off right
once again like we've seen it now with
two people my mom and jessica they both
quickly gained their weight back and you
may not get it back in your stomach but
everywhere else starts to blow up you
know your hips your legs your chest your
face
and things like that especially um like
with my mom and jessica we've seen it
firsthand but
that's what i think that they should do
i think that they should go ahead and
start trying to go to the gym because
when you come back you're not going to
just like want to go and hop off in the
gym you're not going to be motivated
more motivated than you are you're going
to be in pain from a surgery
i'm so nervous about the pain too like
me and pain are not good like
uh uh pain is not my friend pain is not
our friend but pain's gonna come either
from a surgery or pain's gonna be coming
from pumping iron in the gym yeah so
either way i'm gonna have pain exactly
exactly but you know in the long run it
could both types of pain could benefit
you yeah i definitely think the surgery
could benefit me but i um i'm just
nervous yeah i just think i'm nervous i
think i just definitely need a little
bit more time to think about it for sure
that's well you're not even 17 yet young
lady
all right so
you're not going to be in in new york
city in august getting the surgery um if
i say yes
all right fair enough to be determined
okay are you ready to play nurse pumpkin
oh nice
nice
to both uh alana andrei right
[Music]